we've learned a white shirt with a mass
over his head what color is the mask
it looks like a Freddy Krueger mask if
you got a like a Halloween mask
yes disturbing 9-1-1 calls just days
before Halloween when a suspect
allegedly pulls a gun on multiple people
all while wearing a Michael Myers mask
Smith was wearing a mask during the
crimes that led up to the shooting
The Mask worn by Smith was collected for
evidence
you can see the photo to my left
it is a white Halloween mask it happened
on October 10th in North Las Vegas
Nevada just before 5 30 that evening a
9-1-1 call came in for a man with a gun
at a public park concerning one do you
have a police fire or medical emergency
yes it is a man just pulled a gun on me
when the call dropped officers attempted
to get in contact with the caller again
he later explained he was running for
his life the officers when officers
called you you didn't answer what
happened well I'm sorry I had to get
away with I don't want to get shot
the caller told dispatch the suspect ran
from the park to a nearby car wash he
said the suspect was wearing a Halloween
mask he wearing a white shirt with a
mask over his head what color is the
mask
it looked like a Freddy Krueger mask
well he got a like a Halloween mask
yes officials later released this image
of the Mask The Suspect wore identifying
it as a Michael Myers mask from the
horror franchise Halloween he's wearing
green socks green shoes a white T-shirt
and a Freddy Myers
a separate 9-1-1 caller from a nearby
grocery store reported seeing the masked
man as well we haven't I work at Terry
Mini Mart we have a guy out there that
has a gun and he's pulled it on a couple
of customers he's trying to wacko North
Las Vegas police officer Anthony molier
responded to the 9-1-1 calls he arrived
to find the suspect later identified as
44 year old Christopher Earl Smith still
wearing the Michael Myers mask upon
officer molier's arrival he made contact
with Smith
who was wearing a Halloween mask in the
park the north Las Vegas Justice Center
body camera footage shows malir
attempting to call out to Smith telling
him to stop hey please stop right there
hey stop
stop right there it's police officer
malear opens fire after Smith walks into
an area with five bystanders and reaches
for a gun in his waistband put your
hands up
put your hands up dude I'm not playing
with you stop reaching don't reach later
investigations found molier fired eight
shots Smith was shot in the arm leg and
torso he died as a result of his
injuries
Smith was armed with one black nine
millimeter Rooter that was later
determined to be stolen and
the weapon battery by strangulation and
evading a police officer had he survived
he would have faced multiple charges
including robbery with a deadly weapon
and possession of a stolen firearm
officer malira was placed on paid
administrative leave as the
investigation continues for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie